You're supposed to read this week was
gray marble of the limbic system and Basal
Ganglia.
It's a hard paper,
but it's easy compared
to the options paper,
which was Swanson.
And I had everybody read that last year,
but you know,
people were basically having convulsions.
And so I decided that it
wasn't really fair to get,
you'd read it.
However,
I would very much
recommend that you read it.
And because it's a bloody
brilliant paper and the old,
you'll learn so much from
it that it will be worth,
especially if you're interested in the
scientific element of psychology at
Swanson.
He's a smart guy and that's a great paper.
And one of the things I
really liked about it,
and this is what I'm going
to an end about grades,
papers as well.
They're there,
they're there.
You're describing brain physiology and
the relationship between that physiology
and behavior in a way that's sufficiently
sophisticated so that I actually think
it's psychologically revealing.
It's,
it's so,
it's,
it's useful and important
to know these things.
And I think what's happening,
you know,
I've been thinking more and more that
that hierarchy that I'm showing you guys
over and over,
I really think that that's
basically a map of the unconscious.
It's something like that and it's
not that hierarchy I showed you isn't
obviously a fully worked out
representation of the unconscious,
but it's,
it's not a bad schemata.
And I think what it's missing is that,
you know,
the at near the bottom where
you have the actual actions,
those actions are actually sequenced
into what you might call a motor melodies
that have a perceptual
frame associated with them.
And then those are nested inside
fundamental motivational systems.
And Swanson's paper does a
lovely job of detailing the,
the physiological substrate for that,
you know?
So basically what he shows is that
the nervous system is built up of
hierarchical modules that start in the
body that basically start with spinal
reflexes.
You know,
sort of quick and dirty spinal
reflexes that cause your,
your,
your people think of their
brain is in their head.
It's like,
no,
there's a big part of
your brain in your head,
but a huge part of it's
distributed through your body.
So I re I re,
I remember reading and
I hope this is correct,
that there are more neurons in
your autonomic nervous system,
then there are in your central nervous
system and the autonomic nervous system
is distributed throughout the body and
it's the part of the nervous system that
governs all the things.
You're too stupid to take care of,
like how your liver works and how your
heart should stay beating and how you
digest food and you know,
complicated things that consciousness
isn't capable of dealing with and you
don't want to,
you know,
you don't want to downplay the
complexity of those sorts of functions.
There are so important that evolution
doesn't let you mess around with them.
So,
and then,
um,
you know,
the,
the voluntary motor system
and the sensory system.
So the central nervous system,
well,
you know,
your spine is fairly hefty bit of neural
tissue and then of course the neurons
themselves are distributed
through your body.
So really your brain is
distributed through your body.
And there's also a tremendous number
of neurons in your gut as well.
And some of those seem to actually produce
information that might actually even
acquire consciousness.
Now,
I don't necessarily need it the gut level,
but it certainly informs you.
So,
so Swanson's basic proposition is
that it's a Piagetian proposition.
You know,
that you lay out these initial reflex
of behaviors and then they're sequenced
into more complex melodies.
The,
the,
uh,
you know,
the lowest level,
highest resolution behaviors you practice
and practice until you're an expert at
them.
Like,
you know how to grip,
you don't have to figure that out.
So you've got these elements of behavior
that you can basically parse off to
automated systems.
And some of those automated systems are
so automated that they're handled by
very low brain areas,
like spinal levels.
So for example,
if you take a paraplegic person and you,
and you,
uh,
if you take a paraplegic person and
you suspend them under the arms,
over a treadmill and tilt them forward,
they'll walk has pretty remarkable
because you wouldn't think that.
But walking isn't that complicated.
I shouldn't say that.
Walking could be,
can be handled by the spine.
Figuring out where you want to walk.
That's more complicated.
So higher order brain
systems are involved in that,
but so you think about it as a hierarchy.
Now one of the things that that,
ah,
at Swanson really concentrates on is
this is the function of the hypothalamus
and she'd tell you some
things about the hypothalamus.
It's Sorta sits at the top of the,
of the spinal cord and it's,
it's not that big.
It's a little bitty brain area.
Although it's,
it's also not,
you know,
you got to remember that when you hear
a word like hypothalamus or word like
emotion or word like brain,
those are low resolution words,
right?
The phenomena itself isn't homogenous.
And so if you look at the hypothalamus,
it's composed of modules and then those
modules are composed of modules and
those modules modules are composed of
modules and all the way down to the
cellular level.
And then there's some modules there
and that goes all the way down to the
molecular level.
And then there's sub module
is at the molecular level.
So it's really,
really complicated.
And to think about it as a homogenous
system is just a low resolution
representations.
So the hypothalamus isn't an entity,
it's a group of functionally related
entities that are composed of groups of
functionally related entities.